-♪ W-W-Whoa, w-whoa ♪
-This one goes out to anyone
who's ever been left waiting.
-We feel you.
-♪ W-W-Whoa, w-whoa ♪
♪ I just found
the funniest meme ♪
♪ With the most adorable dog
that I've ever seen ♪
♪ So I text it to my friends ♪
♪ Saying "OMG literally me RN,"
then send ♪
♪ Now they're
typing something back ♪
♪ Still typing something back ♪
♪ I just wanna know
what you thought ♪
♪ But all you said
was three dots ♪
♪ So I update my laptop ♪
-♪ Text still three dots ♪
-♪ Watch a couple TikToks ♪
-♪ Play hopscotch
with street chalk ♪
-♪ Text still three dots ♪
-♪ Stitch a cozy for my teapot ♪
-♪ My girl been writing back so
long that I been wiggin' out ♪
♪ Like 15 minutes, man, I wonder
what she writin' 'bout ♪
♪ Gotta know what the text
is gonna be ♪
♪ It's like little bubbles
making fun of me ♪
♪ Baby, hit "send" quickly ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't take
these ellipses ♪
♪ Every text from you
gets me so hot ♪
♪ Now all I got is three dots ♪
♪ So I practice my jump shot ♪
-♪ Text still three dots ♪
-♪ Dance to the beat drop ♪
-♪ Make a plan to win an EGOT ♪
-♪ Text still three dots ♪
-♪ Watch "The Office"
on Peacock ♪
-♪ Text still three dots ♪
-♪ I appreciate taking your time
to respond ♪
♪ But while you've been texting,
we wrote a whole song ♪
-♪ About waiting and waiting,
it's almost too much ♪
♪ You could at least give
my last text a thumbs-up ♪
♪ But the text on three dots ♪
♪ Gray and bouncy three dots ♪
♪ 'Bout to yell it
from the treetops ♪
♪ 'Cause the text
on three dots ♪
[ Cellphone chimes ]
-Oh. Ah.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
-Nice.
-♪ Text still three dots ♪